I don't know what they wanted.
I just wanted to know where's this going?
What are we doing here?
I remember that night.
I'm sure they both do.
My name is Jason and I've been with Joe for Toby or technically newlyweds cause
he just got married and not so great.
Uh,
my name is Joe.
You've started this relationship for a few months.
My name is Matthew.
Um,
I wasn't expecting this to happen.
I was hanging out with them and then things just happen.
Hey Jason,
can you hear me?
Hey Matthew.
Perfect.
Ready?
Yeah.
Were you worried about being Paul are Amish?
Um,
no,
I wasn't really worried like ever since I've been with Jason I've always thought
love who you love.
And I've never just made it into just one person.
I wasn't worried about it because I feel like everything is an experience and I
feel like we should experience these types of things.
I was actually with somebody else and I felt like that just wasn't going
anywhere anymore.
And so eventually something just pushed me to be like,
I just need to be happy and I seen to go for it.
And so I decided to leave the person that I was with and to start pursuing this.
And I think the biggest thing I was scared of is what everyone one's perception
was going to be.
But when it comes down to it,
it doesn't matter.
I'm not doing anything wrong.
I don't think so.
Mm.
I think in the beginning there is always that like uncertainty.
We're like,
okay,
for me in general,
like we're really open.
So if we're like,
okay,
you know,
we both really feel him and like we both,
why him,
this is who I want in our relationship.
Okay.
What do you think,
I think I just bring this sense of joy and peace.
What do you think that Joe brings to the relationship?
Responsibility?
Cause he's always like,
he's always like,
don't do this,
don't do that.
Matt brings,
I'm like in love with Matthew.
So,
and of course I'm in love with Joe and I have been for 12 years,
but like Matthew coming in,
it's like,
it's like those butterflies again.
You know what I mean?
So I'm sure Joe feels same.
I think I bring humor.
I think I bring,
um,
a sort of calmness.
Jason is,
he says he's not that smart.
I mean he could be kind of dumb when he says things,
but I think he brings intellect and then Matthew as much older as we are,
he brings us new experiences that I haven't been known or haven't seen.
Definitely a sensitive adventure.
I think Joe brings like a more,
so if something goes wrong in my life,
I'm not going to be like,
hey Jason,
it sounds messed up.
I'm not going to be like,
Hey Jason,
I need your help with this.
I'm going to be like Joe,
like I need x,
Y,
and z.
This is happening right now.
Like what can we do?
I think Jason allows me to not be so uptight and not be so caught up in myself
and they bring out these different parts of me that I don't think one person has
been able to do for him yet.
So
yeah.
Do you ever worry that you would love one of them less than the other?
I don't know.
I think it's sorta like I'd given that I will love Joe more considering the,
the dynamic and the duration and experienced that me and she'll been together
and I don't think Matthew would be surprised about that.
However,
as far as like the love that I put out into this relationship,
I don't want that to be an EPN are and distributed equally.
I love both of them really do this love is pretty,
I feel like it's locked then
and this love is very like,
it's fresh love,
so it's a work in progress kind of love.
I don't say it's like loving one person more than the other.
I think that we experience different people in our lives for different reasons.
For me,
I don't think it's a matter of me loving one person more than the other.
I think that I loved them differently and I think that's expected because
they're different people.
So not one person.
Am I going to love the same way as I love another person.
What do you think is the hardest part about the relationship
is just,
I don't know.
I Guess Matthew to be on this because me and Joe,
I sorta have that stability and that security that I have and then Matt coming
into this relationship and me being like so in Aberdeen and infatuated with him,
it's like where does he stand?
Like where,
when can I have that stability or that security?
So okay,
if this doesn't work out and they ended up together and I'm alone,
that's just my,
but of course they decide to be the one to be left out.
I know my character and I know there's so if they feel like they'd want to move
on without me,
that'd be okay with that.
Think the hardest thing for me is what's next.
And I think that's a normal thing to feel,
but I don't want to keep dwelling on what's next.
Even though I do,
I'm guilty of it.
I just want to keep living in the now and keep pushing this forward instead of
trying to worry about what's coming.
I don't necessarily care what people say,
but I know there are negative people and they don't want to understand.
But like if you open your mind,
if you just like anything,
open your mind to anything,
I think that's when you can stop being so negative.
And I feel like some people just do that because they aren't happy about
themselves.
Does your family know your poly?
Everyone,
but my mind,
I dunno.
It's like almost coming out again.
It's like being gay was one thing.
I already got kicked out for that and I think I'm just scared that she'd be
like,
what the heck?
I've never really told them,
but they see it on social media.
I think I expect a reaction when I tell people like,
I'm like,
oh cool.
Look,
people were asking me what's going on in my life right now?
Um,
I think the craziest one to tell what was going on was
actually my mother.
Um,
but I mean,
when it came down to it,
she's like,
hey,
like as long as you're happy,
I'm not going to stop you from being happy.
And not a lot of people have that.
Some people can't even tell their parents that they're gay.
And I'm lucky enough to be like,
hey mom,
I'm gay.
And I'm seeing two people.
All right.
How do you all feel right now?
I can read my name and they can see you.
I can remind to Matthew,
Matthew.
Matthew,
what about
I love you both.
So if you're happy together alone,
I'd be okay with it eventually.
But I think saw me off guard.
I said that too.
Um,
I agreed.
we do believe in many different variables so these things might happen and if
they happen,
they will happen.
That's why I think we are,
we're less hurt about it because
will you ever need to know?
There's so many situations.
Yeah,
I love you both.
We'll see where ends up.
Hey everyone,
if you're lonely like me,
subscribe,
then we can be lonely together.
Uh,
and if you want to just check out more videos,
you can watch him right here.
Cause if you're lonely,
you probably have nothing else to do.
So in the meantime,
I will be right here waiting for you at the end of another,
both sides up.
So peace,
love and blessings.